so again the narrative that is now
coming out from the left
and it's gonna they're gonna try and run
this all the way to the election is that
trump is soft again on white supremacy
now do i think there's gonna shift votes
no i think we've done this routine
several times before it seems like it
comes up every several months
so joy behar is uh the the most blunt
instrument in the democratic arsenal so
here she was
yesterday on the view suggesting that
trump himself was a white supremacist
yes i'm sure that's right i'm sure that
donald trump the guy who signed into law
criminal justice reform
who moved the embassy in israel to
jerusalem
whose daughter is jewish and whose
grandchildren are jewish
and who has evinced tremendous love for
both jews and black americans
and there's a guy going back decades was
hanging out with like don king
here's joy behar talking about how how
donald trump is not just
soft on white supremacy again he's made
comments in the past where i think he
was
did he do that the other night no he did
not she doesn't just say he was soft on
white supremacy she goes
ho-ho because that's joy behar she's
never met
anything like a moderate statement she
says instead donald trump is himself a
white supremacist
can i just say one thing so of course he
doesn't denounce
white supremacy sonny because he is a
white supremacist
americans have to decide whether they
want a white supremacist in the white
house
we've never had it before maybe we
didn't know we had it but we
certainly know we have it now okay no
no no no okay so here is here's the
white supremacist yesterday so the white
supremacist in chief yesterday
here he was he was asked specifically
about denouncing white supremacy
here was his answer they should stop
defunding the police like they've done
in new york
like they've done in new york i just
told you
i've always denounced any form any form
any form of any of that you have to
denounce
but i also and joe biden has to say
something about antifa
it's not a philosophy these are people
that hit people over the head with
baseball bats
he's got to come out and he's got to be
strong and he's got to condemn
antifa and it's very important that he
does it okay so first of all
he's right he's absolutely right here
that the media have completely ignored
the fact that during that debate joe
biden refused to condemn an actual
violent group antifa who've been
committing acts of heinous violence
and up to an including murder in
america's major cities and that's gone
completely by the wayside like he openly
did that okay you didn't have to read
into the comments to get there joe biden
literally refused to condemn antifa from
a presidential stage and no one gives a
damn in the media
that's an actual violent group the vast
majority of the violence happening in
our cities right now the city is burning
that is not white supremacist it is not
white supremacists in chicago
and la and new york and dc is not white
supremacist in portland
it's not white supremacists in seattle
there's a bunch of left-wing groups
joe biden has been able to get away with
that because the media are so
militarized against trump that they
seriously do not care
if joe biden decides to make excuses for
antifa and chris cuomo was a big
antifa defender in the early days he
still occasionally
will kind of let that mask slip a little
bit so he's right back but the key quote
there
is of course i defend this i uh of
course i denounce white supremacy
i denounce all forms of this i've always
denounced all forms of this
okay so let's just replay for the sake
of people's ears and eyes who are you
going to believe
seth rogen and joy behar and the members
of the new york times editorial board
or your own ears so i'm gonna replay the
exchange that happened from the debate
the other night
and see if you can find in here donald
trump not denouncing
white supremacy seriously there's
there's only one way that you can get
there and i'll explain in a second
but you have to have the preconceived
notion going in that trump is a white
supremacist in order to come away with
that conclusion
okay let's play the clip are you willing
tonight
to condemn white supremacists and
militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared to do this okay stop right
there for a second
he has now said in the first 10 seconds
of this clip sure
twice sure and then he says again sure
i'm willing to do that and then trump
turns right he turns and he swivels and
he says i don't understand why we're
talking about right-wing violence in
cities that are being dominated by
left-wing violence i don't understand
this why aren't we talking about blm why
aren't we talking about antifa that is a
perfectly legitimate point
okay and then wallace because he was
terrible the other night decides that
he's going to double down on this
yes sir but will you conde he already
did twice he said sure
two times if he wanted to say no he
would just shake his head or he would
say no you think donald trump
is is unwilling to say things that piss
people off he does it all the time
okay but the fact is that he does condem
white supremacy he does condemn
these people who are committing violence
in the cities if they're from the right
okay like i'm sorry but okay so there's
only there's literally a three-word
thing that trump says in the rest of
this exchange that everybody on the left
is hanging their hat on to claim
that he is in fact a white supremacist
okay and the only way
you can read this is if you think that
trump is exact with his language which
we all know he is not
it is amazing how the left which fully
understands that donald trump is wildly
in exact with his language that donald
trump routinely says dumb crap
how suddenly they get super serious and
meticulous about his literal language
all the time now listen i understand the
left saying to people on the right you
know you guys you say that you should
take him seriously not literally and
that
that lets him out of the that lets him
basically say whatever he wants to say
and we're supposed to read into his
words but i don't even take him
seriously i've said this all along
i've been very consistent about this i
don't think that virtually anything
trump says ought to be taken seriously
because i don't think that he's the
world's most serious person
i don't think it's possible to look at
trump and think he's the world's most
serious person i think very often
there's a core of truth to things that
he says
but i do not think that he is exact in
his language i don't think that he
thinks out what he's doing beforehand it
doesn't okay so here is the rest of the
exchange
do it go ahead i would say almost
everything i see
is from the left wing not from the right
what are you saying i'm i'm willing to
do anything i want to see
peace sir say it do it say it
do you want to call him what do you want
to call him give me your name give me a
white supremacist
and write prophecy boys stand back and
stand by
but i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what somebody's got to do something
about antifa and the left because this
is not a right-wing problem
this is a left direction okay so stop it
there so
he already said right at the top sure
twice i'm willing to condemn white
supremacy and then
the thing stops dead right for the first
time the entire debate it stops dead
because he literally is confused you can
see he's confused they're saying to him
both biden and wallace then do it sir do
it he's like i don't know what you want
me to do i literally just said that i
condemn
the white supremacists and i condemn the
violence in the cities who are we
talking about like i don't know who
we're talking about and the reason he
says i don't know who we're talking
about
is because the left lumps every single
human being together the left pretends
that everybody they disagree with is a
white supremacist
okay this is unfortunately a common
left-wing trope is that everyone they
disagree with is a white supremacist let
me give you a perfect example so
yesterday joe biden releases an ad
okay this ad is about donald trump not
apparently
fighting back against the white
supremacist hard enough you'll see even
in the chris wallace question there he
says
white supremacists in right-wing militia
groups okay so
number one you can condem anybody who's
getting involved in violence that is
illegal
that's fine but if you are going to say
that all of these quote-unquote
right-wing militia groups are the same
ideologically as white supremacists that
is inaccurate
right but the the left likes to do that
ideologically they're not the same
the left has now grouped together for
example patriot prayer which is a not
racist group
with actual white supremacists who are
in fact racist joe biden did an ad
yesterday
where he grouped together he in order to
in order to group together everybody
who they disagree with they grouped
together kyle rittenhouse and
and white supremacists who were marching
that unite the right garbage people
rally
okay kyle rittenhouse for all the idiocy
of going
to a riot site with a gun okay
he shouldn't have done it i've said that
a thousand times he is not a white
supremacist there's no evidence he's a
white supremacist joe biden groups him
together with the white supremacist in
this ad
so here's that ad from from joe biden
yesterday are you willing
tonight to condemn white supremacists
and militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared to specifically
do it i don't say i would say almost
everything i see
is from the left wing not from the right
what are you what are you doing what are
you saying
i'm willing to do anything i want to see
peace sir
do it say it you want to call him what
do you want to call him give me your
name give me a white surprise
and you'd like me to continue proud
stand back and stand by
okay and then okay so here's here's
where they are here's what they are
they're relying on they're relying on
those three words and stand by
okay so what was trump saying when he
said and stand by do you really think
that he was saying stand back and then i
want you to stand by is like a
paramilitary organization
or do you think that what he meant was
stand back and stand down
okay which one do you think that he
meant i can tell you what gavin mcginnis
the founder of the proud boy said
he literally was he was doing an online
follow of this particular
debate and in the middle he said wait a
second he just told us to stand back and
stand down i'm the head of the proud
boys donald trump isn't the head of the
brow boys
so gavin guinness the head of the proud
boys understood that what trump was
saying was stand down
but donald trump isn't the head of the
police okay beyond that
notice the attempt by the left to again
lump everybody in
under one rubric now i'm not a proud
boys guy i don't like the proud boys
i've told them before i don't want them
involved with anything
that i do right they've offered in the
past some of the proud boys to go to
like speeches that i give and provide
security i'm like what the hell you guys
are a paramilitary group i don't want
anything
to do with the proud boys but to lump
them in as white supremacists right that
is the next step so in order to get to
trump didn't condemn white supremacy you
have to make a logical leap here the
logical leap is that the proud boys
number one are white supremacists and
number two
trump was attempting to embolden them
rather than telling them to stand down
okay those are two logical leaps neither
of which is inevitable
number one he told them to stand back
when he said stand by do you think he
meant stand back and i want you to stand
by
in paramilitary fashion i suppose you
could interpret it that way if that's
how you want to
but i don't think that's what he was
saying and i think it's fairly obvious
that he meant stand back and stand down
okay beyond that in order to get to this
point you have to lump together
white okay so he says twice in that
exchange will you condemn white
supremacy
sure okay and then he says who are you
talking about specifically and joe biden
jumps in and gives the name proud boys
hey now
in order to get to trump is soft on
white supremacy you then have to say
that the proud boys are a white
supremacist group
in fact as cnn reported yesterday they
are not a white supremacist group they
may be a paramilitary organization
they may be an organization whose
members engage in illegal activity
they may be an organization some of
whose members have engaged in white
supremacy but as an organization they
actually condemn white supremacy as
cnn's own reporters acknowledged
yesterday
we should be really clear that the proud
boys do not consider themselves a white
supremacist group they have
members from many different ethnicities
that doesn't mean that they have not
wreaked havoc they're more like a
political fight club if you will
um than a white supremacist group and
have distanced themselves so in order to
get to trump is soft on white
supremacism you have to say number one
the proud boys are a white supremacist
group and two
trump was taking leadership of them and
telling them to arm up which he was not
doing which he was not doing
in fact what are the chances that trump
actually knows who the proud boys are
like really knows who they are
trump does this crap all the time
because he has never not sounded off on
an issue
right he says who are you talking about
it's joe biden who inserts the proud
boys into that conversation
trump yesterday was asked about the
proud boys and trump was like i don't
even know who they are
you mentioned a name you threw it out
there i was like okay so stand back and
stand down or stand by or whatever it is
here was trump yesterday i don't know
who the proud boys are i mean you'll
have to give me a definition because i
really don't know who they are
i can only say they have to stand down
let law enforcement do their work
law enforcement will do the work more
and more as people see how bad this
radical liberal democrat movement is and
how weak the law enforcement's going to
come back
stronger and stronger but again i don't
know who proud boys are but whoever they
are they have to stand down
let law enforcement do their work okay
this is a completely manufactured media
narrative this one
it really is there are times when trump
has said things and it is not a
manufactured media narrative
this one is manufactured out of whole
cloth you can watch the clip yourself
you can analyze it yourself
unless you go in with the predicate that
donald trump is a white supremacist you
cannot read that
as a white supremacist statement nor any
of the statements to follow you know
white supremacists generally don't do
the following day again say for the
thousandth time they can then white
supremacy and also
that the proud boys should stand down
that's the thing they don't do
i mean it's amazing the media conflate
every single person
they don't agree with with white
supremacy and then say that if you
condemn those people or if you tell them
to stand down you're a defender of white
supremacy
again go back and listen when i think
that trump has said things that are soft
on white supremacy i've blasted the
living crap out of him
probably more than anybody on the right
actually i won't say probably
certainly more than anybody on the right
that is not what happened in the debate
last night and the attempt to
manufacture this narrative in advance of
the election
is really a media creation and quite a
disgusting media creation
at that and you can see by the way the
media
spinning this narrative up in real time
on everything
you you wonder why there's such a level
of distrust in the country on these
sorts of issues on racial issues
maybe it has something to do with the
media that will somehow come up with the
idea that this was a soft on white
supremacy moment for trump in the debate
and at the same exact time they will
throw out there that kyle rittenhouse is
a white supremacist i mean
remembers the media who are saying this
at the time in kenosha i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the ben shapiro
show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content